before we start coding our content
provider let's make sure the manifest is
set up correctly you need to update the
androidmanifest.xml file within the
application tag to add the content
provider so that Android's content
resolver can see it the authority really
should match your package name while the
name indicates which file your content
provider class is in next let's code up
on create we'll begin by creating an
instance variable for our database
helper in oncreate we initialize our
instance variable we return true which
is how we tell Android that the content
provider has been created successfully
it turns out that we can repurpose the
same tests we did for the database to
test our new content provider this will
allow you to both test your content
provider code and see how the content
provider calls replace the SQLite
database calls let's start by using
Android studio to copy test DB to test
provider let's rename test create DB to
test delete DB so we can start with a
clean slate we'll just leave the EM
context delete database line in there
we'll leave the other tests the same
we'll get to it soon